hey guys welcome to my fourth video of
web scraping with r
in the last three videos we web scraped
imdb wrote some code
i'd recommend checking those videos out
if you haven't already but
in this video we're going to be web
scraping tables we could
go ahead uh let's say we had this data
set of cost of living data
we could go and use the selector gadget
tool and
um select you know all the states to
begin with and then
take this css tag and make columns for
each of these items
but the rvs library actually has a read
table built-in function
or html table function built in so we're
going to go ahead and use that instead
and it's super easy all you need to do
is figure out the name of the table
so i'm going to go ahead and right click
inspect
and if i hover over you can see in the
top
actually where the the little white box
is it says table hashtag
features grid that's the name that we're
going to use this time
so like before we've gotten our two
libraries arvest and d
plier we're going to set a link
i'm going to call this call link for
cost of living
and it's going to be equal to our web
url
we're going to generate the html source
code by calling the read html command
and then we're going to create our table
which is going to be similar in the
sense that it's going to call the
the page piped into html nodes
and now we're going to use that table
features grid that pops up so table
hashtag features grid
i'm going to pipe this again and then in
before
videos we would call html text now we
want to call html table
now this will essentially generate a
table for us
based on all the text from this table
but it's not exactly oops just need to
run our code not exactly what we want
yet
so if we open this up view
all table it's a list
actually inside of the table so one last
thing we need to do
is put a period to signify that we want
to explicitly call
the the data that's right before the
pipe
and then access index 1 which is how we
actually extract that list
so we can run this and now when we view
our call table
this is exactly what we want super easy
honestly a lot easier than using uh the
selector gadget tool but
it really only works when you have a
table on the website
now this doesn't always work and
it really doesn't work on wikipedia
sometimes
wikipedia is a great source of data so
i'm going to show you real quickly
a second example where we grab this
table of apples which is actually huge
because
there are a ton of different apple
species but
all we need to do is again
create our link variable
which is going to be this wikipedia link
we're going to read our page
and create the apple table
so before we inspected the element
right click inspect
and when we hovered over we got
the table hashtag features grid here we
see table.wikitable.sortable.jquery
tablesorter now if we actually use that
i can go ahead and type that up real
quick
wiki page html nodes
and it was
table.wikitable.sortable.jquery
tablesorter
if we just run this we actually
whoops made that mistake again
we actually don't get anything it's it's
a null node set essentially
if you ever come across this and it
might actually be quite common
it's generally because the html source
code that we generated here
is different than the one that we're
receiving on this page
and because this table is sortable it
uses jquery which is a javascript
library
it the code is just slightly different
such that we can't directly grab the
table using this method
but luckily it's not super hard to
circumvent we just need to change this
back to table
and this will actually give us all the
tables on the page
we know that it was the wiki table
sortable
so this is kind of the area where
there's
you know not an exact solution you just
kind of have to play around with it
but this is wiki table sortable we know
that this is wiki table sortable
there are some other tables on this page
but
you you can go ahead and check those
other css tags to confirm that it's not
this one
but once you've done that we know that
we want to extract the second
element so similarly to what we did up
here
we'll do a dot 2. except this time we're
only going to use these single brackets
because this isn't a list this is just
the second element of the vector
and that will get us the actual
individual node but then from there we
need to grab
the html table and lastly
we need to grab the first element of the
list
so we'll just show you what that looks
like if we run through them so
this was what got us uh up to html nodes
table
if we run up to the second element
we'll just grab the wiki table sortable
if we run up to html table
we'll get the actual table but in the
form of a list you can
tell by the
if we go up oh it's going to be very
long but
you can tell by if we view the apple
table
this bracket bracket 1 bracket bracket
that signifies that it's a list so we
just need to extract that
list get it into a data frame
and here we go so this is
all the apples on that wikipedia table
so again this isn't super hard to do
if you already have the table in the
html page it really can be done in a few
lines
but it is a little tricky so just be
wary of that
anyway thanks for watching and if you
have any questions just feel free to
leave those in the comments below
but i'll see you in the next one
[Music]